-We talk a lot about immigrants
right now.
We talk a lot about refugees.
Your parents, your family has
this incredible story which is,
as you mentioned, you came here,
you had a sponsor
in this country.
It seems to have been
very welcoming
in a way to your family.
Is it a story that you feel
comfortable telling these days
with everything going on?
-Well, you know,
my natural inclination
is to not talk about myself,
which is why I'm here
on this talk show.
[ Laughter ]
But I think given the climate,
if it helps to share my story,
so it can humanize a refugee,
I'm happy to share it.
But, you know, I also grew up --
I lived in government housing.
I needed government assistance.
I was one of those kids
who needed lunch assistance,
and that's been in the news.
I needed Pell Grants to go
to college and, you know,
I don't feel like
I'm a scourge to society, so...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's really just lovely
having you here.
Thank you for sharing
that story,
and congratulations again
on your nomination.
-Thank you.
-It's a delight to talk to you.
Hong Chau, everybody.